so why am I the one that's telling you
all of my problems and all of the issues
with me and you failed to mention
something like that and that's a huge
thing because she is the reason why now
you are pressuring me to come out to my
mom there has been the fans who have
come at Stephanie and said like you
aren't bisexual you're you know they've
just come at her hard for that and I'm
wondering what you would say to those
people I don't think it's fair for them
to you know firstly just say it in the
first place to a stranger to even make a
judgement in the first place you know of
course like people can have the doubts
or whatever but like I've mentioned
before like this is Steph's journey and
it's no one's place to like publicly go
for her or what have a conversation with
your friend have a conversation with
your mom or whatever but to like go and
find someone on social media and like
seek them out to be nasty to them like
that that just sucks you know what
wrongs would you like to write about the
experience that you guys had together if
you could honestly I just kind of wish
by you know there was like a
conversation about the parts of my life
that were problems that's honestly just
that the one main thing because I felt
like I was being punished for things
that I had disclosed and then I was
having things thrown at me that I didn't
know about so it was kind of this like
this crazy thing where I was like I was
feeling bad for things but I was honest
about and then I was expected to accept
things that she hadn't been honest about
it I have to take this medication with
me everywhere I go because this is kind
of what keeps me alive
that's concerning is there anything else
that I should know about that I think
there were some people who were coming
at you for the way that you reacted to
her illness a little bit like no no that
honestly watching the singing with stuff
telling me about her illness that was
kind of weird for me because I I didn't
feel like you know mad about it at all
it was it was just something that I was
like calling upset about or anything it
was just surprised because the severity
of it was something that I didn't really
know a lot about at the time oh sorry
you know I was like concentrating really
hard
she's telling me you know a story and I
guess because and probably in the scenes
kind of before that I was like happy the
contrast from like going from like this
like serious yeah kind of resting face
kind of face people which is like oh
like she you know people were very quick
to tell me that I am you know I didn't
care about it or like I wasn't accepting
of it and that wasn't the case at all
like Stephanie will children so I'm not
it's it's never like that you don't want
to do anything you don't want to you're
saying I like meeting new people as hard
you're saying that mean planning dates
is hard literally everything is too much
like why did you even go Mia why like
why bother step how different do you
think your relationship might have gone
if you guys were not longest I think
that at the end of the day like jealousy
issues whether your fire-pot or not
they're gonna come up if you have
insecurities about your partner with a
friend like what I'm you know I'm not
gonna be with my planet 24/7 even if
they're here so it's like it's still
gonna be a lack of trust and you know a
lack of what the wedding is out there
gonna be a lack of dress Rick all this
sorry I don't know yeah I don't know
maybe it would have it would have taken
longer to pan out but I think inevitably
unless you know those jealousy issues
with something that we worked on it's
still
probably put one iPod eventually do you
feel that stephanie was justified in her
concerns with my friends yeah oh
absolutely not
yeah I guess the difference is that I
know that there's nothing to worry about
and you know she has these insecurities
and she doesn't know sorry you know she
comes and she meets them and I thought
it would be yeah like don't worry about
it and it was just it went bad really
quickly um but I think of a good day you
know like their concerns well no
concerns need to be had at all I can
understand being a bit worried about it
but you know my friends and I like every
every single person at that party out of
every one dad I had kissed one dozen
there like it wasn't it's not a big deal
[Laughter]
like language no language barrier but
like a I guess like a cultural
difference in the woods hooking up maker
than that it felt that Stephenie felt it
was bigger than that yeah no absolutely
not
you know that was not I don't know where
this kind of like narrative came about
me being this like sex demon but like I
can have sex with all of her friends
like it's not it's not like oh like our
friendship group is not like that Adam
was telling me he went to get a half the
other day and like the gelding cut his
hair was like so he's a tree
do you and all your friends have sex and
he's like especially small town like
everyone's talking about it
yeah but ya know it's it's not like that
at all I know what kind of pin crossed
like that and I know people are gonna
make up their minds anyway about what
they think about that but my friend went
out like what would you say for you was
the lowest point or the hardest moment
definitely as you know there's probably
two pots that were you know extremely
difficult for me and they were obviously
both huge members in the show so it's
been kind of hard to hear people's
opinions on them but the party scene you
know popped up step left eye that's the
mess you know yeah I was I was very
embarrassed you know I felt like oh my
god I just created all this drama at my
potty like my friend's house that was
really hard but of course then obviously
the the bread thing with the ball was
also something that I really really
struggled with I was you know one sweet
and I shut the cameras off I was kind of
like not in a good place for a little
while about that but you know at the end
of the day that's what happened and yeah
it was it wasn't good but I said that
probably the hottest two pots of
everything to me well what kind of place
for you in and and how did you pull
yourself out of that well I
after the bow throw you know I I
actually sat in bed so quite some time
and I was I was crying it was it was not
good mentally for me like I'm you know I
wouldn't say that I was like fearing for
my life or anything but you know it was
it was a very intense moment that really
startled me and I kind of like put me
into a very negative headspace which was
not great but you know I went home and
you guys saw a nice book to my mom and
for a couple of weeks off of that I was
just like not okay I thought I'd to
spend more time with my friends and
whatever after that though after
spending a lot of time in my bed but I
started to realize and get back to get
back to the mindset that I was in before
the show and realized that I you know I
needed to just get back into the groove
of things and love myself and yeah I
went to Thailand I volunteered and that
was cool so yeah it was I just tried to
spend time doing things for myself do
you think there's anything that could
have gone better like if you could go
back and have it go better for both
sides so that it could maybe be in a
more amicable place is there anything
you would change I mean obviously the
breakup was very intense and it didn't
start off that intense and then it kind
of spiraled very very quickly I think if
I know maybe if I explain if I had the
opportunity to explain what I was trying
to get across it would have been a
little different maybe I know that stuff
you see in the scene she says what I'm
pressuring her and like that was not my
intention at all at all he's just trying
to like you know open up about an
experience that was concerning for me
and like at the time and I was like
scared of it you know I was trying to be
vulnerable and I feel like maybe if I
had an approach that differently maybe
we wouldn't have had that fire and we
had to make me be working on things but
[Music]
the jealousy stuff was our main issue
honestly you know you see instantly like
who is she what is her name why do I not
know about this it wasn't about like
pressuring to come out it was like you
have only friends you know it was it
wasn't anything to do with me like
trying to get them to come out you know
if you had one word to describe it all
what word would you choose a roller
coaster what's your current relationship
status I'm single go back to Thailand
[Music]